[Música]
el gobierno de la ciudad china de wuhan
decidió practicar el pruebas con 19 a
sus 11 millones de habitantes a detectar
el primer brote de transmisión en local
desde mayo de 2000 20 ocasiones por la
variante delta luján en la ciudad donde
el virus se detectó por primera vez en
diciembre de 2019 tenemos reporte desde
beijing
la activista bielorruso de 26 años
vitalicio fue hallado ahorcado en un
parque de kiev la capital de ucrania en
circunstancias que no están claras
la líder opositores de plana tica nos
calla y la velocista olímpica cristina
team a no busca ya quienes permanece en
la embajada de polonia en tokio
reaccionaron a la muerte de decisión
e irán el ultraconservador ibrahim drive
y fue confirmado como nuevo presidente
de la nación islámica tras haber ganado
las elecciones del pasado 18 de junio el
clérigo cercano al ex presidente roban y
asume en medio de retos como la pandemia
de kobe 19 los altos niveles de
inflación y las negociaciones que
intentan rescatar el acuerdo nuclear de
bienvenidos a una nueva mañana de
información de américa latina y del
mundo aquí en las 24 mi nombre es
liliana valencia iniciamos en la ciudad
china de wuhan en porque el gobierno
decidió practicar pruebas joven 19 a sus
11 millones de habitantes para detectar
el primer brote de transmisión local
desde mayo de 2000 20 ocasiones por la
variante delta buscar en la ciudad donde
el virus se detectó por primera vez en
diciembre de 2019 los detalles con
nuestro corresponsal en beijing adrián
foncillas
el último y más agresivo rebrote ha
devuelto el coronavirus a su presunta
cuna las autoridades han informado hoy
de siete casos locales se enojan que
parece muy pocos para una ciudad de 11
millones pero que han bastado para que
se ordene que todos ellos sean testados
en los próximos días también se ha
ordenado el cierre de escuelas y se
exige la toma de temperatura y el código
verde en el teléfono a la entrada de
centros comerciales y supermercados y
janes en el mundo sólo el origen de la
pandemia pero en china también simboliza
la lucha más eficaz contra la pandemia y
se explica que las medidas tomadas hoy
sean contundentes incluso para los
parámetros nacionales sus ciudadanos
pasaron en el origen de la pandemia 79
días encerrados y hasta esta mañana
sumaban un año sin contagios locales
debido a su extrema precaución los
metros hoy volvían a ir semi vacíos y
algunos habían corrido a las tiendas
para aprovisionarse de víveres china ha
informado hoy de 90 casos son ya una
decena de provincias las afectadas por
el rebrote que nació dos semanas atrás
en el aeropuerto de nanjing cuando uno
operarios limpiaron un avión llegado de
rusia las autoridades explican que este
rebrote es más difícil de atajar porque
detrás está la variante delta mucho más
contagiosa que las anteriores
hay conmoción en belarús ante la muerte
de la activista de 26 años vitality soft
quien fue hallado ahorcado en un parque
de quiebra capital de ucrania en
circunstancias que son objeto de
investigación la líder opositora
svetlana tica nos calla en el exilio
reaccionó diciendo que ni siquiera
afuera de su país los hielos rusos
pueden sentirse seguros y la teta veloz
rusa kristina tema no busca ya quien
permanece en la embajada de polonia en
todo que tras denunciar que su país
quiso obligarla a abandonar los juegos
olímpicos
sostuvo que el muertes como la de sisov
son típicas del régimen de belarús
en cuanto a los peligros y todo lo demás
en vísperas de estos eventos hace tres
semanas en un mitin regular en la plaza
maidán vital y me dijo que debíamos
tener cuidado ya que los servicios
especiales de la república de belarús se
estaban infiltrando en los grupos de
protesta identificando a los activistas
y organizadores del movimiento de
protesta y todo esto tiene como objetivo
destruir todas las actividades de
liberación de belarús en irán el nuevo
presidente ultraconservador era jean
rice y fue confirmado hoy en su cargo
tras haber ganado las elecciones del
pasado 18 de junio con un 61% de los
votos
el querido asume en medio de la pandemia
de ccoo y 19 de los altos niveles de
inflación que afectan al país y en un
momento de negociaciones para rescatar
el acuerdo nuclear de 2015 además de su
línea dura raíz y es criticado por
delitos de lesa humanidad por los cuales
eeuu lo sancionó en 2019 y organismos
como amnistía internacional han pedido
que sea investigado la ceremonia de toma
de posesión ante el parlamento se
celebrará el próximo jueves con
presencia de delegaciones extranjeras
a la vista está guardado
el mensaje del día de las elecciones fue
un mensaje de urgencia para aliviar los
problemas económicos y culturales de
nuestra sociedad como amigo farhangi
jaume wood
estos fueron mensajes enviados por
nuestro querido pueblo a través de sus
votos exigiendo la administración
entrante por la que votaron para abordar
los tarcos trias dry de mar dom en
afganistán miles de ciudadanos que
pueden ser blanco de violencia de los
talibanes debido a su afiliación con
eeuu tendrán la oportunidad de asentarse
como refugiados en la unión americana
bajo una nueva designación de prioridad
2 el gobierno de giovane anunció que
ampliará la elegibilidad de los
refugiados a medida que el país retira
sus tropas y que los talibanes
intensifican la violencia en las últimas
24 horas informó de al menos 40 civiles
muertos y 118 heridos
bajo una creciente presión para
garantizar la seguridad de sus aliados
en afganistán el gobierno de bailén
reconoció que era necesario hacer más
por miles de personas que podrían pagar
un alto precio por sus vínculos con eeuu
el programa de visas de inmigrante
especial está definido cuidadosamente
por estatutos y sabemos que hay afganos
que no califican pero que nos ayudaron y
merecen nuestra ayuda tenemos una
responsabilidad especial con estos
individuos ellos estuvieron con nosotros
nosotros estaremos con ellos el lunes el
departamento de estado dio a conocer sus
planes para ampliar el alcance de los
afganos que pueden obtener el estatuto
de refugiado en eeuu para incluir a las
personas que trabajaron para medios de
comunicación y agencias de ayuda con
sede en estados unidos pero también
empleados del gobierno y de la otan que
no cumplían los requisitos anteriores
hasta ahora sólo los contratados por el
gobierno de eeuu tenían derecho al asilo
los nuevos solicitantes tendrán que
salir de alta
están antes de poder iniciar el proceso
de un año de duración en un tercer país
una situación calificada de inaceptable
y por las ong exigir a los afganos en
riesgo que se conviertan primero en
desplazados internacionales antes de
solicitar visados pone aún más en
peligro al pueblo afgano que se ha
asociado con eeuu a medida que se
intensifican los combates los talibanes
toman varios puestos de control
fronterizos dejando a los refugiados
varados y sin poder salir del país según
estimaciones recientes hasta 100.000
afganos podrían acogerse al nuevo
programa de refugiados continuamos con
esta serie de informes especiales sobre
el líbano un año después de la explosión
en el puerto de virus que devastó parte
de la capital el país sumido en su peor
crisis económica y política sufre además
la falta de combustible transportadores
y ciudadanos se ven obligados a hacer
largas filas para encontrar gasolina
allí es chófer de taxi y desde el inicio
de la crisis de la gasolina pasa la
mitad de su jornada laboral haciendo
largas colas como esta
estoy esperando me toca esperar dos
veces al día pasó una hora o una hora y
media haciendo cola y a veces justo
cuando me toca ya no queda gasolina en
la estación
el combustible no solo es difícil de
encontrar sus precios también se han
disparado el estado al borde de la
quiebra debió reducir las subvenciones
para la compra de este producto
la bencina se importa hoy a un cambio de
3 mil 900 libras por dólar en lugar de
1500 una medida que preocupa al i
ayer gasté 100.000 libras para llenar el
tanque en todo el día invertí 150.000
libras entonces solamente obtuve 50.000
libras de ganancia
hoy gaste 65 mil libras en combustible
lo que quiere decir que estoy perdiendo
dinero tengo cuatro niños que alimentar
y no sé cómo hacerlo
pero la escasez de combustible afecta
también otros aspectos de la vida
cotidiana
el problema no es solamente llenar el
tanque sino que es más grande y va a
afectar también las hospitalizaciones el
turismo y toda la economía
todos los productos van a ser más caros
es debido al coste del transporte
por transportation porque para llevar un
producto de un lado a otro necesitamos
gasolina
esta crisis dentro de la crisis afecta
gravemente el estado de ánimo de la
población más que nunca los libaneses
temen que el país no pueda sobreponerse
de este golpe
finalizamos por este informativo pero
ustedes pueden ampliar en nuestra página
web france24 puntocom y formación en
cuatro idiomas sobre el acontecer
internacional nos vemos en 30 minutos
con más información aquí en france 24
[Música]